et l'alcool à un moment tu étais quand
même une bouteille de Chivas par jour je
me souviens moi non
non
c'était Chivas
alors dis-moi comme tu as pas loin de 50
ans
on va faire une petite interview de
shaker s'il te plaît alors la taille
c'est toujours un mètre 80 ça change pas
beaucoup le poids tu es toujours à 85
les dents les dents elles ont toujours
pas méchantes petite
alors j'en ai deux qui m'ont fait très
beau il y a quelques années que j'ai
fait changer
et alors depuis et c'est marrant je
marche mieux les yaourts
ça va c'est incroyable tu as tout tes
cheveux une très belle chevelure quel
est ton secret
quel est ton secret
incroyable
les yeux comment ils vont tes petits
yeux
madame j'aime beaucoup que j'aime
beaucoup vos chaussures vous êtes
élégante mais quand même non c'est vrai
que dans les yeux ça va pas terrible
t'as combien là tu sais à peu près les
numéros
[Musique]
et aveugle voilà
l'activité sexuelle un ralentissement
depuis
la dernière fois c'était dans la statue
de la liberté c'est une dame quand même
quoi
deux opérations ou de bêtises opérés de
la jambe
c'était varice
sont-ils non non je mange les pots parce
que on peut mettre des produits dessus
donc les ongles c'est un petit peu dur
est-ce que tu as des maladies chroniques
maintenant tu es très cocooning
finalement parce que je disais l'autre
jour un article te concernant qui avait
été écrit au début des années 60 et
alors ils étaient tous en train de se
déchirer et tout et toi tu étais avec
Françoise à Noisy-le-Sec dans ta petite
maison
le fait que
des journalus emmerdeurs viennent vous
voir donc si on est tranquille ils ont
rien à raconter donc ça permet de faire
toutes les conneries du monde sans qu'on
vous emmerde et ça c'est très important
et les enfants ils sont casés ça va
j'en sais rien
comment ça va bien ça
mais pourquoi mais je sais pas parce que
tu as pris un moment de substance un peu
plus illicite quand même non
tu disais une petite ligne c'est bien
avant d'aller chez guilux ah oui tu
viens
non plus dit qu'il fallait en prendre
un sourire là-bas merci
et l'alcool à un moment tu étais quand
même une bouteille de Chivas par jour je
me souviens moi non
non c'était Chivas heureusement que tu
avais pas le permis à l'époque dis donc
quand même
tu te rends compte pourquoi bah parce
qu'avec une bouteille de chinoise par
jour l'Alco test
il est pas question de conduire puis
heureusement que tu es pas une femme non
plus
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu